welcome to this video playing baritone
burrito burrito and baritone vs. soprano
that would be a good matchup okay anyway
let's see we get some ratty googled
counter position I can't just ok let's
take not a huge expert on those lines
get it too often so how is much playing
this year some groupie one cannot be too
bad using the half-opened file swears my
night going in this kind of position hmm
or just you form ID for this Bishop f5
that's very likely no good hmm
oh no this is maybe I mean Bishop c6 is
there is the one more threat but I'm
more thinking about like 94 95 this kind
of thing + d 4 now is more interesting
now yeah typically quick play my black
94 maybe 94 Bishop g5 is something that
I don't know f6 is not a very welcome
move I think but he seems completely on
unperturbed ok I can even go all the way
back but even he is not so bad I've got
to eight out of nine against this this
person pretty good score don't want that
to change ok let's see
thinking about Queenie to and ce4 maybe
if he puts the night on c4 ok I'm going
here and then take my bishop it's not so
bad k crew takes on my eggs yeah maybe
nine ticks
here just here attacking the pawn we
white structure sound like the bishops
don't don't look too threatening at the
moment so I feel okay in
don't really see how he covers a seven
just good for wider I guess or does he
have something really active going for
him okay so I still don't see why I
shouldn't take mean this Bishop is not
exactly improved maybe 94 to c5 was even
better now that I think of it that's not
a bad square them left and sometimes I
in general I'm not playing too quickly
and I still get those time traveled but
sometimes I choose the wrong moment to
be quick here 94 was an even stronger
but okay it would be a very quick when I
don't see how he how he keeps the peace
now up to 8 9 p-6 black resigns John
it's probably some kind of theoretical
position that looks the whole um cause
of the game I felt very a very logical
do uniform yeah I'm not sword upon this
like e6 not quite sure what this move
does preventing Bishop e3 maybe also I
don't know okay here b6 and now i
provoke this I don't really think it is
that that bad
for black maybe we can go if I've also
should be should be kind of okay so
nitey five here oh I can just take him
just go at five hahaha oh wow I
completely I completely blundered that
night here I was just thinking okay he
went 95 he will go nights before I
didn't think about this for one moment
and it has no squares absolutely no
squares oh my god yeah no I'm okay and
here he overlooked between 8-6 I think
yeah I think I going downhill here for
black even though that wasn't wasn't
necessary and here 94 is even stronger
than night c4 maybe it's not a big
difference as he has a hard time to to
keep his things some are coordinated I
mean look at those bad bishops wow I
could have played f5 I think I should
take a break here thanks for watching